when you talked about retiring you I
think you tweeted about retiring from
chess give me the video Yeah and tweeted
um it's my values of the world
the Tweet or the video it's just the
both yeah
um I'm retiring from all competitive
chess events my preparation is
outmatched my calculation skills are too
flawed and most importantly my anxiety
is beyond repair I physically and
emotionally cannot do it anymore what
was the hardest thing uh what was the
hardest thing about competing like can
you can you elaborate on that
yeah
I think it's separated into faces of my
life so after being a Creator and coming
back and playing over the board and
making Recaps of all my games
I think
the
constant feeling that I had at the board
was a kid who hadn't studied enough for
a test
which is a very unique type of anxiety
and
during the game it was just self-hatred
like good moves did not feel as good as
how bad bad moves felt and bad moments
and and underneath that you're saying
there's a sense that I did not prepare
well enough oh one unquestionably so
my I'm an international Master but
there's International Masters now who
are 11. I got the title when I was
22 which is late that might not sound
like it's late but it's really late and
I quit just multiple times when I was a
teenager if I hadn't one of my parents
was like sit down this is the only thing
that you're good at focus on it yeah
maybe I would have been a grand master
but that's that's life right and I would
come back to Chess at various points in
my life when I felt more mature I felt
more ready and I felt more motivated I
was all me I never I had one coach when
I was maybe about 10 I never listened to
the guy great guy like he emailed me
even recently just wanting to catch up
which I thought was adorable because I'm
not I don't even know if he knows that
YouTube chess exists he's in his 70s
he's just he's just like a nice older
guy yeah um and he would come to my
house we would have dinner and my
grandma would make us food
and he would tell her that I'm brilliant
but I never work
and I have so much potential if only I
ever worked at all one minute on
anything I just played Speed games
online and
and what did he did he speak the truth
there like could you have worked more I
could have worked more for sure yeah
absolutely when you listen to Magnus who
doesn't he seems like he doesn't work
either he works uh he might work in
different ways but I think for him it's
also uh Obsession again love it's it's
everything it's he might read a book he
doesn't consider it work it's work he's
getting information in and he's learning
something it might just be easier for
him to learn than
for me for example or for anybody just
everybody learns and absorbs things
differently so I I would come back to
chess and the best run of my life that I
had was in 2016 where I basically while
teaching a chess program Scholastic
chess program I told all the parents hey
so for these four months I want to stop
doing private lessons and I'm gonna go
travel and play tournaments because I
want to become an international Master
finally I'm 20 years old this is in
2016. like can can you help me raise
some money these are all managing
directors these are lawyers these are
seven figure eight figure households and
they contributed and I kept the blog and
then I worked just six hours seven hours
every day like studying all the opening
Trends uh all of the new ideas reading
the books analyzing my own games playing
my own speed games and analyzing them
training every day and that year I went
from 20 to 40 over the board to 2404
with two of the three Norms as they call
them which are basically tournament
performances like you perform at a
certain level not too complicated so I
got almost everything I needed to be an
IM
but I just slipped up at the very end
and 2017 I didn't play chess but in 2018
I came back once again with the
Vengeance I started playing in the
summer once again and I went up up to my
Peak
but then something interesting happened
my life mission was accomplished
I never wanted or thought I could be a
Grandmaster yeah I wanted to be an
international master
and the adrenaline dump of hitting the I
am title
I just stopped working completely which
is completely stopped working I I
couldn't and the second I started
falling
I couldn't stop
and I spent the rest of the summer just
tanking and I said [ __ ] this I'm I made
my made my I am I'm gonna I'm gonna [ __ ]
off someplace and whatever I'll be I am
it doesn't matter
uh but when I play games online I mean I
destroy Grandmasters all the time
like dynamically Dynamics and chess were
just complex positions with all sorts of
calculation attacking defending like
very forcing lines
I think it's my best strength I think
I'm easily Grand Master Level so that
you have the capacity to be Grandmaster
100 like if I if if the work was put in
if the work was put in and I I was not
doing my current career if I just
train full-time
I think I could do it do you have a
desire to be Grandmaster
did you have a desire you said I didn't
really want like the main goal was in
international Master which by the way is
a really interesting just I've talked to
Olympic athletes the crash after the
gold medal
is fascinating I didn't get gold but for
me that was my that was your goal I mean
it doesn't matter it's the goal yep
uh it takes a very very special person
to not be destroyed by the gold and
continue the dominance yeah it's to
continue growing to continue I mean it's
hard to that's why they talk about it's
hard to be a champion and defending
championships or whatever the goal is to
achieve the goal and stick to like
um
yeah who broke me it broke you yep you
see you have the capacity to be a
Grandmaster have you ever
thought by the way is there still
possible for you or you have fully
dedicated now
to the love of creating and analyzing
this game I don't think I'm going to do
what I do right now forever